hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to kevin
samuels
i have to admit i'm going to admit when
i first started listening to him
i really did not like him did i call him
a douchebag
i did i stand
i partially stand by him however
i've been warming up to him a little bit
the more i listen to him
so i'm going to take you guys along with
me on this journey as i react to more
kevin samuels
uh before i for before i start this
youtube channel
oh my gosh i cannot talk today before i
start the video do not forget to like
comment and subscribe especially
subscribe because
the more interaction i get with this
post the more interaction i get with
this channel
the more motivated i am to keep making
content on here so if you like this
channel
do not forget to like comment and
subscribe okay
i'm pull
okay let's go to youtube i'm just gonna
pick like a couple clips i've watched
some of these already
okay let's see
is twerking classy this seems
interesting
okay
[Music]
oh my gosh this is two
hours no i'm sorry but no we're gonna
find a different video that's like
shorter all right kevin samuels
clips
prove that these girls will be terrible
oh god that's very loud
[Music]
kevin's here kevin samuels in the house
all right let's drag him
okay welcome back all right shout out
kevin samuels in the house man welcome
kevin
people yo what's up man good um
hi hi ladies how are you
one so we're talking about two different
things one
part of image called digital footprint
once it's on the internet it's forever
[Music]
and uh i don't know how your backgrounds
but i would tell you as an image
professional
people have spent upwards of a hundred
thousand dollars to remove everything
off the internet and they still can't
get it done
um find me a fortune 2000
ceo that is happy to have
naked pictures of his woman out there
men care we are territorial
so just like the one woman who says the
two
married people there um that's anecdotal
and one thing i i want to ask all the
women there
myron's been trying to give you what men
think and you've been pushing back
why is it so hard for you ladies to
accept that we think
differently than you do
okay i agree with this point um
especially when i was younger i would
wear like
outfits where don't get me wrong like i
looked
i looked good i'm not even gonna lie to
you but there's a lot of outfits i wore
when i was younger
that i definitely regret and
i mean they weren't anything like crazy
like no like half naked pictures or
whatever but just like stuff that was
like too short
and i really feel like the older you get
the
more you realize how unclassy that is
and just
how it's better to really keep yourself
like
put together at all times
but i mean i never i think these are
only fans girls so that's like a very
different
territory we can start here yeah you
guys if you guys talking to mike you
start hearing i didn't go wrong
okay so i mean it's that hard to accept
that it's just saying
us women we have our own opinion as well
so
i mean i accept a man's opinion and how
he feels but like how i said i'm not
going to go for the guy that
thinks that way i'm i'd rather stay
single and find somebody that thinks the
way i do and so
okay so understand something
you control access to sex we control
access to relationships and marriage so
it's not your choice
it's the man's choice and it's the man
that accepts right
um right right so we're not talking
about a man that you don't value
see a man that you value a woman values
see this all sounds well and good for
when you're in a power position with the
man and you can take him to leave him
but what about a man that you want
i don't want a man that doesn't want me
i'm sorry to say so
you could have this is the difficult
question though
so basically what you've said is you
haven't met a man that you value higher
than yourself
um i've met a man that i value higher
than myself but i wasn't ready around
that time because i was not just not
ready
now that i look back at it i'm like okay
i should have valued that man because
he was good enough for me because he
accepted me for who i am
but coming across other men that are not
like that
i mean i'm not gonna a guy that doesn't
accept me for who i am i'm just gonna be
like okay on to the next one to the man
that actually accepts me for who i am
so if you ask a different woman this
question that actually wants to pursue a
man that is she's interested in and
doesn't like her for what she does
then she might just give you the answer
that you're looking for but
this is an interesting point i'm
interested to see how
he's going to react to this because i
hear women like talk like this
all the time i'm looking for actually
i'm looking for what i'm looking for is
the truth and then how well you learn
okay okay i hate the term my truth
like what do you mean you're true that
makes no sense there's
the truth but what i'm looking for
i'll let you speak can i can i have the
opportunity please yes sir
what i'm looking for is not your truth
i'm looking for the truth the truth is
not really subjective
it's that's one thing that with modern
women today i mentioned on my program
whenever you press modern women it tends
to get the truth become subjective
variable or extreme now
now with you say you're not looking for
a particular man that's fine
but mine is my thing is this when women
are
looking to finally settle down and be
found by
someone men think different than you do
especially men with options
i agree with that but there's different
women different personalities and
different people in this world so
i'm like how i said before i'm sticking
to what i'm saying
i'm not like most women of course
there's a
woman that is like that of course she's
going to be like
you want to settle down and i want to
like i said it's always that
how do you okay
um you'll think differently probably
about 37.
no i've already thought about this i
already told myself about it
accept me for who i am i'm just gonna go
to sperm bank and just raise a child
myself
this is the buy dog guy alone and
okay this is
if you can't find anybody to accept you
for who you are do you think that maybe
you need like some internal changes some
stuff you gotta work on
guess what you're free to have that
you're afraid to have those guys
that's the beautiful thing about this
country women are free to buy dogs
have sperm bank children and die alone
no one's going to stop you
but i'm talking about the kind and
caliber of men that you women would want
see like i said again this is easy to
say when you're in a power position
you're still
at the peak or closer to the peak of
your hotness but
10 years from now uh it will change
it always does halle berry is
complaining about child support
and bitching about having to pay money
and i don't think anybody on this panel
was hotter than halle berry was and not
not the hottest person in hong kong in
the world
four years in a row four years running
so
i don't know see my mother grow
better man i mean i don't know like i've
seen my mother would grow
and uh she's been in two marriages and
she was not posting her ass out there
and she got tried by my stepfather
and my dad too and i mean like i've seen
how my mother
has been always a good woman and
these men well men in general certain
men
not all men because i can't say all men
are the same i'm not gonna be sexist or
biased in that sense
but i'm just gonna say that some men
most men
most men how
i hate it when girls do this i hate it
when girls do this
how can you say i'm not going to be
sexist or biased if you're going to say
all men or most men oh she just said
sorry sorry let me correct myself
if you're not gonna say like she just
contradicted herself by saying
most men what if they said most girls
cheat most girls
are hoes most girls whatever like you
wouldn't feel some type of way
don't appreciate somebody so i see my
mother
raise me the type of woman that i am and
she's always told me
you don't need somebody to define you so
if you want to have somebody
my mom's an eye surgeon what is your
father
what'd you say your stepfather my
stepfather
yeah what about him what did he do he
owns a corporate company for cement okay
so your mother was an exceptional earner
yeah she was an exceptional earner okay
all right so her options and your
options
and most women's options are different
so your mother raised you to have
you can believe what you want i'm not
trying to change what you believe but
what i'm trying to understand
is how often do you modern women
understand how men think
and see that's what myron what myron was
getting to push forward
i'm hearing anecdotal my mom like this
my that do you understand how
men think i do i have a conversation
with my father all the time that's one
man
because i don't know if you guys truly
understood how men
think the amount of pushback you guys
are giving myron would have been
much less but see this is what happens
when you tend to speak to women who are
younger and kind of around the peak of
their hotness
you are you you can the world is still
your oyster
now if you want to make examples based
upon an
eye surgeon all right but i don't know
many people whose mothers are eye
surgeons
but most women need a man to get from
one point of life to another because you
earn less than us
the average median income for the woman
in this country is 28 000 25
123. the average man is 34
36 000 a year you need two incomes
so most people can't get to the end of
life so this whole variable notion about
i'll just
have a baby on my own such and so forth
unless you're talking about making 150
to 200
dollars for the rest of your life i
don't know how you plan on doing that
comfortably
the goal i have a quick question that's
the goal what are your high income
skills though
i'm studying cyber security um
engineering and i'm
coming up to 120 to 200k a year so i'm
okay
okay and i'm a chemical engineer and i'm
gonna tell you that
that is that is what i mean
but she is sassy she is set they need to
get some more
i hate in these type of podcasts they
always have like
the trashiest least i mean i don't know
these girls personally this could just
be a bad clip
but like it seems like they always pick
the trashiest
like only fans girls that like
just do not like not very level-headed
that's the no
that's but that's not the new one and
see
and what i what i hear from a lot of
modern women is you've cherished you
cherish your independence
more than you cherish what a man brings
to the table it's like if a man can't
pay his weight
pay 100 away for you guys he's not
useful
well i think you guys are going to
realize something in the next 10 years
that
the world has told you that you can have
it all you can't
life is about choices and trade-offs for
us all
i have a quick question good life is
about choice
i'm surprised from the first video to
this video i'm actually surprised at how
much
more i agree with kevin samuels because
that's really true you
can't like okay i grew up in a family
that was
very like well-off like if you go
through my youtube videos you'll see
like our house tour is like
a huge huge giant mansion and
i don't think most people realize like
what that comes with
like when i was growing up my dad like
now i spend so much time with him i love
him like literally
one of the coolest people i know but
like growing up i didn't see him much
like honestly i did not know him very
well and that was a trade-off
that he chose and i understand it i'm
really grateful for it now
but a lot of people aren't willing to
work like 12-hour days
for most of their kids life in order to
like get that
so on one hand like i definitely
understand what he's talking about with
like trade-offs and it's the same thing
with like woman
in a career versus a family um so
uh piggybacking on the idea that she
said that uh she'd like to raise a kid
on her own what about those women that
didn't necessarily
because we're talking about like whole
comparison things so what about the
women
that didn't choose to raise a kid on
their own yeah like right so like
obviously so like for example it's like
you're asking me
uh well you and like everyone else first
of all
women of the 50-plus percent divorce
rate women are filing 78
of our divorces women are choosing to
wreck their own homes
every day men are not choosing to wreck
their own homes and make women single
parents
that's a choice that women are making uh
why because their husbands are trash
treating them badly
but why is she making that assumption
you have no idea what the main reasons
are
okay now you now here we go with the ad
hominem stuff
we put this name
this is the same stuff that's been piped
into the culture forever
okay and i have an observation half the
time the women
that say things like men are trash men
are the worst whatever
they are the same girls that choose to
date trash men like
every single one of these girls is
absolutely stunning i don't
it seems like i'm not positive but i
thought in the title it said only fans
these girls would be too oh no no it
doesn't so i don't know what they do for
a living and that if they are
in like some sort of sex work that could
eliminate like the type of guys that
want to date them
not all i'm just saying like a lot of
guys aren't into that but like
they're beautiful they're they're hotter
than me i'm not even gonna lie
like absolutely stunning you they have
the option to date guys that are nice
and that are kind and caring but if they
continue
to choose guys that aren't nice kind and
can't like
kind caring whatever you look for like
you can't blame men for that that's your
own fault
like it's not like any of them are super
overweight super unattractive whatever
like that when a woman chooses to break
her home it's
always the man's fault i was more so
asking a question from like the child's
like
first day of birth right children have
birth certificates and it's the woman's
like responsibility to sign it it's not
the man's responsibility to sign it they
don't have to sign it like anything
wait wait wait wait wait wait so i was
asking no no no no no no no no it's not
true
okay it's not true no don't hold up
that's not ma'am that's not true
if you're married it is your
responsibility to sign your child's
birth certificate
but if you're not is what i ask that's
the point you should marry before you
carry
that's an opinion that's not a that's
not an opinion that's fact
it is statistically who's the psychology
major who's the psychology person on the
panel
children do better in a two-parent
household in general yes or no
yes thank you
facts but i don't
i don't understand what that necessarily
is because
the child has because the union of
marriage is one of the best
institutions they human beings have to
date for the rearing of children
it's permanent it's the primary reason
so this whole see
there's no emotion about i have opinions
but i also have like the psychological
like you know what i'm saying like
there's an opinion
what i what didn't see what i'm what
you're still hearing there's a lot of
women on the panel who
understand your points of view but
you're hearing less and less about
anything i mean it's always
every time i've asked a question about a
man it's been something negative
something detracting it's not
nothing has been positive
i just simply asked a question in
regards to like because you said
um oh do you expect to make a hundred to
two hundred thousand to support that
child
um in regards to valentina so i was just
curious like what you think about the
women who don't have a choice in that
well you do have a choice do you really
have to make a hundred to two hundred
thousand to support a child
because statistically wouldn't that not
make sense
don't only 10 of men make 100 000 or
more
so if you need 100 to 200 000 like
numbers-wise that doesn't really make
sense
like i don't know
just question you can let me know in the
comments actually because i don't have
the answer to that question
you just don't like your you don't like
your choices you chose the man you laid
down and made a baby
you chose to bring a child into the
world for that man then you can choose
to do your duty
but psychologically like we were
speaking earlier
again those are your choices see those
are choices and if
and right now again i want you guys to
go back and clip this
every time i've talked about a man
there's been something negative
or or downside yet to hear anything
positive about anything regarding a man
relationship or the benefit of a man and
a woman working together
does that have what i'm saying about the
man or us though
see this is this is the counter argument
so i grew up in a two-parent home i'm
really
like even though my parents like were
gone a lot because they worked a lot
like
i'm very grateful that i grew up i
almost grew up in a three-parent home
because we had a nanny too
but like
i'm thankful for that i think it was
really good for me and my siblings but
on the flip side
i have friends that grew up in a
two-parent home and
they wish their parents would have
divorced earlier because they argued so
much
so it's
tough because not everything's black and
white every situation is different
but i don't like that that's like where
i get a little bit like
like can i put it that's where i
i'm trying to figure out a way to phrase
this like i see the benefit and i can
understand like why statistically
growing up in a two-parent home
but i guess it goes to the exception to
the rules where my mind goes
but i guess it could be either way right
yeah because if we have nothing positive
to say
then in our experience there's been
nothing positive
because of the men you choose to date
well then well if that's the case you've
picked them
um so everything is the tr our choice
right yes yes
i i used to be i wasn't this far gone
but i used to feel like this like better
trash men are the worst
and one day i just had to wake up
look in the mirror and say look
there's one common denominator in all
these situations
it's you me at the time and
after that like i went into dating with
a whole different mindset like
because i realized that my dad's not
trash my brothers aren't trash like i
know so many quality men
so going around saying men are trash is
like wow it's only the men that i date
that are trash
so having that mindset wasn't true
or fair oh yes you picked yes ma'am you
because just like every man you've
chosen
there have been other men who may have
been suitable but you may not he's not
tall enough he's not this he's not that
there are no women on this panel that
are hideous you get to pick
yeah no this is what i was saying
earlier because
that was because i'm pretty tall and
that was a realization
my boyfriend now is pretty tall too but
like
i realized that i turned down a lot of
guys that actually would have made
like good boyfriend material
because of like one or two superficial
things instead of just looking at them
as a person
see what you cannot do is what women
typically try to do
absolve themselves of all accountability
and consequence
i believe that everybody gets
consequences for what they choose to do
however
well i don't hear any on this panel she
just said what did you say what about
the women who didn't do this this this
what about the mothers who didn't choose
what you did i didn't list anything i
specifically asked you a question in
regards to children
who just spoke before you
[Music]
yeah as a single mom i agree with him
saying like okay
like i chose to lay down and you know
for the man or whatever
but when you're saying like oh i chose
to like like give birth to the kid
like what about if you found out you
were pregnant when you were seven months
pregnant
because that was my situation like
how did you not know you were pregnant
for seven months it was like you're
having the baby or you're like
that's just your responsibility like
it's just
there's or giving up the baby for
adoption but that's like that my mom
wasn't gonna do that like that's more
like you know like
sorry how does that well so first of all
so let's answer your question
most women don't find out they're
pregnant in month seven
huh i mean that's just not the norm
especially with all medical technology
today
you know you have a monthly cycle it
does not come
that's usually trick one there are many
options down that path
but again you found out you had a baby
on the way he
did have the option to give it up for
adoption you just chose not to exercise
that
still a choice oh okay i agree
and then you were saying something about
marriage certificate right that the the
somebody was asking about the birth
certificate i asked why
in most cases it's the mother's
responsibility to take care of a child
instead of the fathers because men and
women so i was just asking in that
instance
usually like the court the court
assistant looks immediately to the woman
no not true and the thing is
if you have a child and you're married
and the divorce is not final 11 months
before the child is married
the father's name goes on excuse me let
me finish my example just on finish and
then you can make your point
if you're married and define of divorce
and your ex-wife has a baby
less than 11 months after you're
pregnant after your divorce is final
the father's name the husband's name
goes on the ex-husband name goes on a
birth certificate
this is a side note can you imagine
being married to
kevin samuels like
i i just feel like you would be roasted
every single day
that's federal law okay
so it's not so it doesn't just
automatically default to a woman the
man's name was on a birth certificate
my name ended up on the birth
certificate
like the majority we're talking about
the majority not everyone has children
after they get married and you guys are
focusing on the relationships that come
from marriage
but that's a choice and you have
children if the choice of a woman has a
child before she's married her after
that's a 100 percent her choice
he's trying to say the woman has to take
accountability that she had the child
out of wedlock
comes with that that's what he's saying
but why don't the men that's what i'm
asking
because because let me answer this i'll
answer this i'm gonna answer this
because
because this is this is what okay does
amen can a man
force a woman to have a child if she
chooses she does not want to carry it to
term
but then it is a woman's choice when a
life is
when a child is born in this country men
have no rights
after conception my mother was a single
mother and she will tell you she
believes the same thing i do
she chose to not get married before she
had me and she chose this
the circumstances in which she raised a
child
he's right he's right on that because
it's our choices women
he's right on that because it's our
choice as women we make that choice
and make these conscious decisions but
what i'm saying is you can't control
like the fate of no i i get what you're
coming from
like we make those decisions but we
can't control
you can control those decisions like
abstinence you don't have to have sex
obviously that's hard most people don't
do it
but there's also a million forms of
birth control
like you're basically stating like okay
um i had sex with this person why can't
they take responsibility too i get that
but like it's also a man's choice if he
doesn't want to be there but it's also
your choice if you want to keep it
right off of the psychological aspect
like they were talking about earlier
like he said it's amazing
what it comes down to is let's just keep
it a stack man i'm gonna just say
because everyone else is too scared to
say it most
isn't that the guy that always yells at
people for interrupting when he just
okay two men don't have any type of
accountability when it comes to
child rearing having children every and
the consequences that come with it
you pick who you have sex with you pick
women have unilateral control on who
gets born
in the united states men have zero
access to that so if you're a single mom
it's your fault and then on top of that
let's also add on that women
initiate 80 of divorces and most
breakups
so it's not that the father isn't in the
life a lot of the time he's not allowed
to be in the child's life
if we're going to keep it a stack that's
true i agree with you because i know
some women like that i already
understand what you're saying a lot of
women use a child as a pivotal point to
exercise leverage to cause pain in the
man's life it happens
this is why this is why i marry before
you carry because in the example you
were given
what about if a woman does this most
time when my man is having sex with a
woman
it is not to get her pregnant they're
having casual sex
it's not like he said you know what
let's have sex and i want you to be the
mother of my child
if a woman if and that's then this is
the thing i tell men don't trust a woman
on birth control
you better back up twice because if she
gets pregnant you lose
you lose because it doesn't matter what
she said before it
after she's pregnant you lose all
because this is 100 her control see i
believe in a world where women have
freedom of choice
you choose to be a mother choose not to
be a mother but then i also believe in a
world where men have the right to do a
financial abortion
you can kill a baby i should not be able
to have to take care of it if you choose
to make me a father when i don't want to
be one what
that's understandable that's true but
it's circumstantial like i said before
in my opinion well but here's the thing
let's be real
if the child support system was fair to
where if a woman chose to
that man could actually sign off his
rights not be financially responsible
not have you come afterwards
do you think the the out of wedlock
birth rate would stay steady
increase or decrease decrease
thank you
dang okay
okay i actually wait let me let me move
this so it's back to the other scene
i actually agreed with a lot more of
what he was saying that i
than i thought like before
when i first like saw kevin samuels
i was kind of iffy but honestly
i can't even think of one place where i
disagreed i think divorce
there is a reason for divorce at times
but that's not the norm like i would
agree where like the majority of cases
like it's stuff that could be worked out
anyways let me know in the comments do
you agree
disagree um where do you think i
was you know right or do you think i was
wrong
and don't forget to like comment and
subscribe i will talk to you guys next
time